salut un câlin plus là on est à quatre
séries avec du casting pour le flambeau
et ce soir on monte les marches si on va
faire la présentation des deux premiers
épisodes je stresse pas mal mais ont par
contre on rigole on est à cannes sous le
beau soleil de cannes ça fait vraiment
plaisir de venir dans le sud alors qu'à
paris il est beaucoup plus beau que ça
mais bon c'est la vie en direct du
plateau du cercle où ce plafond
on enchaîne avec le photocall c'est au
palais suis moi toute ma
quelques voeux accueil
[Musique]
m'a tellement les doigts les doigts les
doigts d'avoir regardé ce qui se passait
moi c'est mon premier photos collages à
doué et voilà effet le double oui
j'arrête que les photos nul deux mois et
qu'elle le ticket
c'est quand même la deuxième fois que je
viens j'étais nuit à un an et demi pour
présenter de la flamme et c'était trop
cool j'espère que je vais réagir on
enchaîne un peu un peu la promo on a
fait télé 7 jours télé loisirs énergie
c'était trop bien et on a pris un
maximum de plaisir moi je vais faire le
bain de jeremstar on se retrouve après
aller à tout j'ai cru que j'allais juste
dire j'ai fait le bain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voiture
tout le monde est en costard et moi tout
le monde me dit non mais t'inquiète
vient tranquillement ça à la cool c'est
tranquille puis en jordanie
[Musique]
ces rames
[Applaudissements]
le jour retrouver sur cette idée folle
par bordier division aventure qu'elle
touche la suite
[Applaudissements]
allez maintenant on va dîner c'était
plaisir déguster notre série à jouer